genius einnahme der polarisiert der
immer wieder für skandale sorgt seit
corona steht das unternehmen von clemens
tönnies massiv unter druck uns werden
neue belastende unterlagen zugespielt es
geht um wirtschaftskriminalität im
großen stil zum ersten mal packen
hochrangige insider aus dem tönnies
umfeld aus
die recherchen für uns bis an die
niederländische grenze wo eine ganze
firma plötzlich verschwindet nur wenige
stunden nachdem wir dort waren ich will
keinen ärger mit antonius haben keine
ärger mit herrn john hughes wieso sollte
es der ärger geben wir sind der spur des
geldes gefolgt und wir haben erlebt wie
sich im umfeld des konzerns in den
letzten 20 jahren ein verdacht auf
illegale machenschaften an den nächsten
reiht
erinnert ihr euch noch an das früher
2020 als die panini für uns alle noch
neu war und vor allem massenausbrüche in
sogenannten hot spots die instanzen in
die höhe getrieben haben besonders
auffällig damals die fleischindustrie
mehrere firmen der branche mussten im
mai und juni 2020 ihre arbeit
niederlegen weil sich zu viele
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern mit krone
infiziert hatten das hat die teils
skandalösen arbeitsbedingungen in der
branche endgültig offen gelegt habe ich
mein machen wir uns nichts vor die
wahren ev und offenes geheimnis extrem
lange arbeitszeiten akkordarbeit auf
engstem raum keine pausen schlechte
bezahlung oder enge und schmutzige
sammelunterkünfte zu abzocker mieten als
dann etwas unvorhergesehenes die korona
dazu kommt bricht das chaos aus so wie
hier im sommer 2020 bei der
reinigungsfirma des unternehmers josef b
einer der größten subunternehmer des
fleischkonzern tönnies im lotto und
streiken seine arbeiterinnen und
arbeiter auf dem trainingsgelände
man bekommt nur selten mit was hinter
den kulissen solcher firmen passiert
doch jemand steht uns dieses video zu
ein exklusiver einblick der mann mit den
weißen kittel hier in der mitte das ist
josef b persönlich und er macht den
leuten hier einen doch recht
außergewöhnlichen vorschlag
[Musik]
wir gehen mit den 500 folgen
moment mal 500 euro in cash für jeden
und dann weiterarbeiten als gäb's die
pandemie nicht zumindest ein
interessanter ansatz
josef b dann sehen wir gleich noch mal
wieder vorher schauen wir uns einmal
seinen hauptauftraggeber an die firma
die wie keine zweite für die
fleischindustrie in deutschland steht
die firma tönnies aus rheda wiedenbrück
kreis gütersloh
denn der sommer 2020 war nicht nur ein
neuralgischer punkt für die gesamte
fleischindustrie sondern vor allem auch
für tennis im juni 2020 stand der
konzern massiv unter druck mehr als 1000
der im tennis werktätigen arbeiterinnen
und arbeiter haben sich mit gegnern
gestellt ganze wohnviertel wurde
abgeriegelt und der komplette kreis
gütersloh muss in den lotter und das
bringt damals auch den landrat des
kreises sven georg adenauer auf die
palme bislang eher nicht so als kritiker
des unternehmens bekannt ich kann auch
insgesamt versteht dass es viele
menschen gibt im kreis gütersloh die
ziemlich sauer sind das vertrauen dass
wir in die familie die firma denn jetzt
sitzen ist er auf null also das ist
schon was besonderes für den kreis
gütersloh ziemlich drastische aussage
was war da los das gesundheitsamt wollte
damals von der firma die er treffen der
im tennis selektiven arbeiterinnen und
arbeiter haben sie kontakt verfolgen
aber die firma kann angeblich vom kreis
prozent adressen
wir haben datenschutzrechtliche probleme
eigentlich dürfen wir diese adressen
nicht haben das ist wirkt der
datenschutz
wenn sie jetzt sagen der haben adressen
gefehlt was sind das denn für menschen
die das illegale ich gehe jetzt erst mal
davon aus dass das nicht so ist wir
werden das aber natürlich mit prüfen es
ist ja auch die frage wieso hat es lange
gedauert wieso hat man sich so lange
geweigert welche gibt es dafür der
verdacht auf unregelmäßigkeiten bei
beschäftigungsverhältnissen im umfeld
des konzerns da steht ja nicht zum
ersten mal im raum mein kollege hans
gugel hat damals angefangen zu
recherchieren wie hast du die situation
damals wahrgenommen ja also ich bin
glaube ich wie viele andere auch in
dieser locker und situation über das
gestolpert und bin an hängen geblieben
was tennis dazu erzählt hat warum wird
bei den arbeitern adressen gefehlt haben
sollen und fand es einfach merkwürdig
dass sie die nicht herausrücken wollten
oder konnten
und ja ich fand die juristische
begründung erst mal einigermaßen
stichhaltig aber sie wirklich für mich
ein bisschen vorgeschoben und dann habe
ich natürlich angefangen mich dort auch
einzugraben und habe dann im prinzip
seit dem sommer 2020 jetzt seit fast
zwei jahren dort recherchiert und wir
natürlich auch auf dinge gestoßen auf
hinweise dafür dass da etwas nicht
korrekt gelaufen sein könnte oder
vielleicht auch nicht bei dem ich kann
selbst alles in ordnung war was haben
deine ersten recherchen damals ergeben
ja also den klarsten hinweis den ich
gefunden habe ist ein dokument in dem
turnier 2006 gegenüber den
sozialversicherungskassen
sozialversicherungsträger wirklich
selbst einräumt dass beim
trainingsbetrieb weide mag in sögel
illegale arbeitnehmerüberlassung
stattgefunden hat und zwar etwa im
zeitraum 2000 bis 2005
denn jetzt hat dafür 1,4 millionen euro
an die sozialversicherungsträger
nachgezahlt weil so hat das diese zur
versicherung dargestellt die
werkverträge die damals dort waren in
diesem werk mit den subunternehmern
nicht existiert haben faktisch oder so
auf dem papier existiert haben die leute
die dort gearbeitet haben bei turniers
faktisch so gearbeitet haben als wären
sie dort fest angestellt gewesen von
anfang an und gar nicht bei fremdfirmen
und deswegen hat die
sozialversicherungskassen gesagt bitte
du musst dafür was nach zahlen und
dennis hat das eingeräumte 1,4 mio eur
haben sie am ende bezahlt öffentlich
wurde dass damals nicht bis 2021 die
sogenannten werkverträge verboten wurden
war es ein großes problem in der
fleischbranche dass viele konzerne mit
sogenannten subunternehmen gearbeitet
haben so mussten sie viele arbeiterinnen
arbeiter sollten wir auch schwere
arbeiten
die zerlegung ja erledigt haben nicht
fest anstellen und dann kommt halt so
leute wie der unternehmer josef b ins
spiel
also nochmal da stellt sich jemand hin
und verspricht jedem seiner mitarbeiter
hier auf diesem video 500 euro in bar da
kann man sich schon fragen wieso ein
unternehmer eben wenn es heute sind
circa 50.000 euro nebenbei ja vorbei
bringen kann vor allem wenn man die
vorgeschichte von josef weekend also
fakt ist joseph beuys auf jeden fall
kein unbeschriebenes blatt ist einer der
ältesten und langjährigsten turniers sub
unternehmer also subunternehmer des
tennis konzerns der die reinigung der
schlachthöfe für den technikkonzern
macht und der erst 2006 verurteilt
worden zu 1,4 millionen euro geldstrafe
und zwei jahren auf bewährung wegen
betrug und steuerhinterziehung letztlich
die zurückgingen auf den einsatz von
schwarzarbeiter was man sagen also
illegaler beschäftigung
josef b hat über
scheinrechnungen geld generiert
sozusagen das eingesetzt wurde für die
bezahlung von schwarzarbeitern und diese
schwarzarbeiter haben dann in einer
anderen wurstfabrik reinigungsarbeiten
ausgeführt diese andere fabrik das war
nicht turniers oder das waren keine
firmen des konzerns war eine andere
wurstfabrik aber fakt ist die haben dort
gearbeitet wurden schwarz bezahlt über
geld was erzeugt wurde über
scheinrechnungen
scheinrechnungen um illegale arbeit zu
tun eine methode die dort unseren
recherchen auch im umfeld des konzerns
angewendet worden sein soll ein
hochrangiger insider aus dem unternehmen
spielt uns brisante dokumente zu die
fakten sind die folgenden also es geht
um eine unbekannte firma oder kaum
bekannte firma an der holländischen
grenze die aber auch nicht weit weg ist
von der konzernzentrale von turniers und
die soll in erheblichem umfang also für
millionen angeblich hähnchenfleisch
geliefert haben antonius jedenfalls hat
sie dafür rechnung soll sie dafür
rechnung gestellt haben aber sie soll in
wahrheit nie was dafür geliefert haben
das heißt es sollen scheinrechnungen
gewesen sein und mit dem geld was dafür
von dem trainings konzern ausgezahlt
worden sein soll sollen dann
schwarzarbeiter in erheblichen umfang
bezahlt worden sein die firma und die es
geht ist die beiden is gmbh aus vreden
nahe der russischen grenze ein
handelsbetrieb für hähnchenfleisch bis
heute hat die firma keine richtige
internetseite das management des
konzerns soll auf jeden fall von diesen
vorgängen diesen dubiosen vorgängen um
die weiter ist gmbh was gewusst haben
die behauptung ist das wirklich internen
dokumente zirkulierten zu dieser weiten
des gmbh teilweise zwar geschmerzt aber
aus denen hervorging dass die tarnung
dort ideal sein weil tatsächlich diese
weiten ist gmbh oberflächlich
zumindestens mit hähnchenfleisch handelt
und trotzdem aber bekannt war in diesem
management kreisen eben das in wahrheit
das geld benutzt wurde um
schwarzarbeiter zu bezahlen und das
scheinrechnung gewesen sind was macht
denn die informationen dieses insiders
in deinen augen so glaubwürdig
die informationen des internet es ist
deswegen so glaubwürdig weil er nicht
nur einfach irgendeine behauptungen
aufstellt sondern weil er auch dokumente
liefert und zwar interne dokumente aus
dem trainings konzern einen screenshot
aus dem warenlieferung system an dem man
wirklich nicht einfach an kommt aus dem
hervorgeht dass die beiden das gmbh gar
nicht als lieferant überhaupt angelegt
waren dem system bis märz 2009 10
sondern nur als kunde und wenn sie was
geliefert hätte dann hätten dort in
diesem screenshot das ist so etwas wie
das profil sozusagen der beiden das gmbh
in den tennis system dann hätten unter
diesem unter diesem profil die letzten
lieferungen zumindestens irgendwie
hinterlegt sein müssen und das findet
sich dort aber nicht jedenfalls nicht
läuft dieser unterlage
2016 lag der umsatz der beiden ist gmbh
noch bei bescheidenen 1,1 millionen euro
doch genau dann als die firma begonnen
haben soll scheinrechnungen turniers zu
stellen soll er plötzlich explodiert
seien auf 9,7 millionen euro 2017 14,4
millionen euro 2008 10 und schließlich
16,8 millionen euro 2009 10 das 15 fache
angeblich wurde ab 2017 ein neues
konzept verfolgt mit maschinellen
großanlagen gearbeitet obwohl die firma
weiter in denselben räumen saß
wir wollten uns die firma mal genauer
anschauen und sind hingefallen
[Musik]
also wenn die ihre hähnchen
produktionsstrecke nicht gerade in einem
zelt vor ihrer lagerhalle aufgebaut
haben dann weiß ich nicht wie dort
maschinelle großanlagen aufgestellt
worden sein sollen das ist mir
vollkommen schleierhaft das war eine
kleine vielleicht
500 quadratmeter große
gewerbeeinheit aber das war keine
produktionshalle keine riesige und ja
das war einfach total widersprüchlich
dass das was man dort gesehen hat vor
ort hat null zudem gepasst was die firma
behauptet hat was sie angeblich ab 217
getan hätte um zu rechtfertigen
womöglich mutmaßlich dass sie an tür
nicht so viel liefert das passt nicht
zusammen also ich habe dort an der tür
geklopft minuten lang versucht jemand zu
finden der mir auskunft geben kann
hallo herr können wir kurz sprechen
ich bin reporter.net einige fragen zu
dem geschäft
ich will keinen ärger mit hand an jetzt
haben kein ärger mit ingenious wieso
sollte ist der ärger geben ja weil ich
hier vor der kamera stehe und nichts mit
dem mann zu tun habe nach unseren
informationen sollen sie zwischen 2017
und 2019 hähnchen in größerem umfang ein
hemmnis geliefert haben nein ich habe
nur einige proben geliefert und dann
haben sie gesagt dass sie die nicht
brauchen außerdem waren ihre preise zu
niedrig das heißt das war zu teuer was
ihr angeboten haben ja die beiden des
gmbh hat niemals in großem stil
hähnchenfleisch ein internes konzern
geliefert
und rechnungen haben sie auch nicht für
solche lieferungen gestellt nein außer
für die proben die wir geliefert haben
dann sind es vielleicht 10.000 euro
gewesen ja maximum also fakt ist den
kern vorwurf dass dort arbeitskräfte
geholt worden sein sollen für turniers
und die schwarz bezahlt worden sein
sollen oder illegal beschäftigt den
streiten beide seiten absolut turniers
der diskussion als auch reiten ist das
merkwürdige ist aber bei allem anderen
widersprechen sie sich komplett erwarten
ist sagt wir waren kein lieferant für
tennis oder nur in sehr geringem umfang
wir haben für maximal 10.000 euro
rechnung gestellt und tennis selbst sagt
auf der anderen seite nein ein weinendes
wahlen lieferant für uns und zwar über
mehrere jahre und weisen das hat für 1,4
millionen euro an uns was geliefert das
passt überhaupt nicht zusammen da kann
es auch kein missverständnis geben oder
so das ist fakt nur eine von beiden
geschichten kann stimmen und die frage
ist wer die wahrheit sagt und das noch
viel krassere war das unmittelbar
nachdem wir dort gewesen sind bei der
weiten des gmbh die firma insolvent
gegangen ist also ich habe ein paar tage
später im handelsregister bzw bei
insolvenz bekanntmachung de nachgeguckt
zufällig weil ich noch mal checken
wollte angaben über die firma unterhalb
festgestellt die haben dich gemacht also
die eigentümer selbst haben ihre firma
in insolvenz geschickt unmittelbar
nachdem wir dort gewesen sind und nachts
clemens tönnies im konzern und der
geschäftsbeziehung gefragt haben und das
ist nicht der einzige verdachtsfall auf
dem wir in unserer recherchen im umfeld
des konzerns gestoßen sind auf der spur
des geldes haben die menschen getroffen
die schwarzgeld hunderttausende von euro
in bar von bulgarien nach jeder
gegendruck gebracht haben sollen wir
haben die offshore briefkastenfirmen auf
zypern nachgespürt und werden natürlich
auch den turns konzern mit den vorwürfen
konfrontiert
dazu gibt es eine ganze folge die spur
in der zdf mediathek wir würden uns
freuen wenn er dann mal reinschaut